now to the masters let's talk golf the  masters 25 year old scottie scheffler  you know he entered the tournament as  the number one player and boy did he  dominate the field scottie shuffler  finished 10 under par to win his first  green jacket his first major hey was a  big number for tiger woods as well he  returned to the course he finished  10 over par but he said being back in  the tournament considering the crash  that he had to get through  was worth it  a month ago i didn't know if i could  pull this off  i think it was a positive and i've got  some work to do and  looking forward to it  tiger says he now feels good enough to  play in the british open at st andrews  this summer  so big big recovery from tiger woods and  big win for scotty sheffler